out on the show floor at san diego
comic-con is a large hulking a machine
battle monstrosity thing and jay qatar
pool from white moon dreams as the guy
behind it Jay uh if the game is war
machine tactics and you guys are on the
show floor in a big way yeah actually so
are so war machine is actually an IP
that's built by privateer press and they
they've they wanted to expand it and we
were we were really crazy about it so we
actually launched a kick starter last
year that that did really well yeah yeah
and here you are with a game that's
playable yeah it's gonna be real
Kickstarter games do happen that's right
that's right we we actually decided to
kind of go big with it so we instead of
kind of building like a small small
casual game or something we went for
like a full turn-based tactics game with
a 20 mission single-player campaign and
48 you know playable multiplayer units
and like more stuff come in all kinds of
craziness so very cool so it's going to
be a good time well we've got a match
set up here between you and your buddy
Matt and you guys are poised to start
doing some damage to each other so right
why don't you get these are these the
the eponymous war machines yes these are
walking around it a little bit here so
so anybody who's a fan of XCOM like we
are we're nuts about X comma 2 yeah yeah
XCOM and final fantasy tactics a bunch
of us are still trying not to we we took
we took a lot of cues from from XCOM and
and then there's a war machine itself on
the table top plays you know it's a it's
a tabletop miniatures game where you're
building squads and and you know growing
the growing your army and then taking
out taking out against the other players
and stuff so here we've we've we've
built a squad and we have our warcaster
who's a
she's standing behind the giant war
machines but with this like really sick
looking hick and ready to do some damage
what's right got some weird engine are
back yeah she's uh she's got a little
steam plant on their all these guys are
steam-powered and she also wields a
bunch of magic too so we'll we'll get a
little bit of that going to cool she
controls these uh these war Jack's the
big guys big guys yeah so here we have
the juggernaut mm-hmm and we got the
destroyer back here and then we got and
then we got a bunch of infantry guys we
got the winter guard right here others
guys the winter guard rock tier he got a
little bazooka type thing with him and
then we got we got the man o'war here
okay I you know the bazooka guy I'm like
this he's got to be crazy to get on the
field this giant war machine has an axe
the size of him and a cannon he's
fearless man look at the look hang on
hang on hang on let's all we gonna get
in there yeah look at that beard on that
fellow Hughley determination areas that
some we see we have very real beard
action there so he can take on anybody
so so are our warcaster here sorta she
she controls her war jack so we're gonna
she's going to assign some some focus
points to them that allow them to do
special stuff okay and we'll we'll get
going so we're playing Kate or that's
one faction we uh we ship with four
factions um and then there's two more
coming so this is Kate or against cygnar
so here's a here's one of the large axe
from signor there's another one here the
charger practically tiny compared to the
other one yeah he's a he's a light Jack
and then no we got we got another Jack
who's uh who's got a big old buff on him
so that's the Lancer and then here's the
warcaster for signor striker
nice hair so this debuff is I mean that
is that a warcaster thing or did the
other sort of so the war caster cast
he's he's put a buff on this on this
unit that gives the unit more defense
okay so you probably want to focus your
attack on the big guy right front center
right yeah yeah he's he's looking like a
he'd like a piece of that but since
we're since we're in the middle of
battle here i'm going to go ahead and
take this moment to use my use my
casters feet which is a it's an attack
that you have once per game but since uh
there's a couple of his guys around i
want to take advantage of the situation
and I seagate ICJ's and that's just boom
so that froze that froze whoever was in
her line of sight okay so I'm gonna
start taking some potshots yeah Oh
actually go go write up a letter to them
and just start beating them so i changed
my facing facing is important in the
game and start beating on them it's a so
much better for you to attack from the
side and to not leave your side or flank
expose right that's the whole facing
mechana hats right that's right you
gotta you gotta watch you got to watch
your back you know and people can kind
of creep around you and stuff like that
you take you take a lot of advantage of
that so got like three three separate
attacks on oh yeah and that's the whole
power of like the war caster can assign
more focus to the to the character to
the to the war jack mm-hmm so this guy
well this guy is going to take a little
pot shot at him Oh actually will use the
rocket launcher and it's given you yeah
oh no damage didn't do nothing now did
you like clip your war Jack there there
is there any friendly fire there is
friendly fire so you got to be careful
if the thing had the rocket some of the
some effects have like area effect short
you know so you can you can wipe your
own guys out and sometimes you want to
use that like war Jack's have the
ability to throw to throw characters but
sometimes you want to throw your own
guys like into the
their fight or their squad and just
start you know beating on him from the
center seems like a bit of a kamikaze
maneuver I mean you know how to do to
the fray but hey the it's a tactic
that's right it's a tactic and it is a
tactics game and privateers privateers
whole model for the game is play like
you got a pair alright so here's a pair
of jacks uh you can call whatever you
want alright so this war jack is like on
the ropes yeah that's what those are the
squares is all that is itself as hell
but yeah and since I've frozen him all
my all my attacks for sure are going to
hit so what's up right because it's on
dice rolls underscore this entire
combats right that's right and actually
we have this whole combat log right here
actually an hour you I is all temporary
right now but you can see our our combat
log you can see everything everything is
recorded okay so in case anybody wants
to get nerdy about it or something at
some point they're all the information
is right there I think with a game as
tactically in-depth as this one the
question is not if someone wants to get
super nerdy about it it's when that's
right that's right so you can actually
scroll back through everything and you
know they're there won't be any
arguments to have and speaking of when
actually talk to me a little bit about
the sort of learning curve here do you
guys have sort of you know tutorials set
up is that I mean certainly there's a
certain amount of tactical awareness
that can carry over from the games you
mentioned earlier like a final fantasy
exactly where next calm yeah but you
have all these systems that are unique
to war machine that's right so if if
someone's not familiar with the the
tabletop game how are you guys sort of
welcoming those players into the game so
we're doing a lot actually for that so
you know aside from like a aside from
like you know manuals and stuff that you
can get online the the single the 20
player single player of the 20 missions
singleplayer campaign is an extensive
walkthrough not only through the not
only through the game and all the all
the little nuances of it but this
amazing lower and the world that like
privateer have actually built it's
really really cool so actually the owner
of privateer and the guy who came up
with all with more machine and
everything he actually has written the
story and
all the dialogue and everything oh no
kid hey he's super hands-on it's really
cool that's cool for you guys to get to
have that kind of connection yeah you
know to this force material yeah it's
really nice and you know the the the
fact that we can work so closely with
them means that the game is really
authentic to everything that war machine
you know that war machine players the
existing more machine players are you
know familiar with so all right so
you're you're putting your guys right in
there I feel like this is the moves you
to finish off the I'm gonna give it a
shot but I I gotta like even other
concerns he's gonna he's going to come
out he's gonna come out strong here or
he's gonna come out at least swinging so
we go for trying hit is hit that guy
over there that's a long range shot yeah
I was out of the freeze ray dias so yeah
so he wasn't frozen but that was pretty
strong role I mean you almost got me
right in the NOC amount i was hoping to
cuz uh cuz this is I mean look at the
size of that guy right mhm you figure
right yeah you should be able to knock
that dude on it boy if I did if I uh I
rolled a little bit better i would have
a i would have done it rolled 15 to hit
10 out of three dice so and you were
telling me this earlier but uh the the
sort of folks are seeing the the blue
outline the red outlines those are
that's sort of a familiar language in
terms of yes XCOM games that's right the
blue you can move and still take a turn
the red is you can get there but you
can't do anything once you're there
right right so will will actually do
that will move somebody into into some
trouble there dangers oh right and then
the yellow is the sphere of influence
that the war castor has that's right
okay right very good i remembered and
the the the game the way war machine
itself is plated you know like it's not
it's not one of those games where you
kind of you kind of like run up and
shoot and then like back off it's it's
all about like getting into people's
faces and fighting so like one of the
things that's that's happened here we
have these two guys who are face to face
now and they're there
actively engaged with each other if one
of them breaks that engagement they they
are prone to get spanx really hard so
this whole there's a whole concept of
free strikes you know you it's if you
get too close to somebody and don't
engage them you can you know you can
take massive damage if you try and run
away from a fight that you're engaged in
you take massive damage is that just
because running away will leave your
flank exposed for the next players turn
punish you for that right okay and
that's a that's a you know that's that's
one of the things that's you know one of
the big one of the many things that
really differentiates the the gameplay
styles you know between other tactics
games and and you're not sort of doing
this stop and pop stuff it seems like
once you're in it you're in it is a very
that's sort of a very aggressive mindset
yes yeah it's very much about being
aggressive or like sneaky so so what
cuttin when you say sneaky I mean I'm
looking at the battlefield I'll see a
lot of guys you could do some sneaky
maneuvers there's I mean you're seeing
two of the four factions here okay the
there's a there's there's so there's
another faction called Crick's which
they have you know they they have
strength in numbers but they also have a
lot of very you know they have a lot of
interesting tactics that you can use
units that can pass through other units
and things like that okay so you'll
which might be good for dumbing
battlefield positioning certainly and
also getting taking advantage of the
facing right can it that's right that's
right all right take this iron flat out
come on let's see if we can do it we've
got a 74 74 percent chance to hit and
the probable damage is as to but if we
create we can get four to six you just
need one right we'll just need one just
need one so let's let's hope the dice
gods are with us I believe in you oh
yeah counted crit all right going down
he's down
sad time for ironclad all right all
right now if Matt's turn to beat up on
you a little bit yes we'll see how that
goes for you so what's his smoke bomb I
mean I feel it oh it finished yeah he's
so you're also seeing on the the combat
log mm-hmm sort of the duration of
different yups and status effects and
stuff like that that's right yeah you
can see everything you can see
everything that though that both players
are doing and you know it's having
anything that's having an effect on the
game mm-hmm so so now he's probably
allocating focus and then figuring out
looks like he's got his a Lancer
selected so he's gonna try and do some
damage with the Lancer now during this
phase you you're just kind of sitting
back and watching and maybe like you're
planning your you're planning yeah
you're planning your next move a lot of
people a lot of people have we've
noticed a lot of people like spend a lot
of time you know going over the stats of
all the other all the other units and
we're also implementing a dynamic camera
system very similar to what XCOM had so
so you can anytime anything is going on
on the field like if you want you can
have the camera like zoom into it and
take a very cinematic angle to it and
watch this small soldier just getting
stabbed repeatedly by a sphere twice his
height dude his beard is keeping them
safe power of the beard all things are
possible right now this is a 1vs1
multiplayer match that we're playing on
a land connection you mentioned the
campaign that's a single-player a fare
against sort of free yes that's
tablished scenarios you guys have yep
yeah so there's a there's a there's a
single player and then there's also a
single player mode we have that's just
called onslaught where it's a AI or just
coming at you they just keep coming at
you and it's a survival mode shirt yeah
we have that and we're going to expose
that to our dedicated server setup so
people can keep lookin a lot of your
guys are all of a sudden lying on the
ground yes he he cast earthquake which
just knocked a
a bunch of my guys over so now they're
they're quite sad sorry you're saying
about dedicated server talk I couldn't
let the dues line down on the job go
without comment you know this is uh this
is one thing we keep a who how do we
make them not look like they're sleeping
or lying down the job and we just may
have to live with it I don't know could
you put IE you can't like put debris on
top of them where did that come from
right now mysterious debris but yeah it
terms of the the online so online now ah
so online mobile what we'll have is uh
we already have we already have
matchmaking going so you can play with
your friends over steam and all that
sort of thing and we have a dedicated
servers coming up so people will be will
have ranked ranked servers will be doing
tournaments and things like that and we
have some we have some awesome sponsors
actually behind us oh really yeah so
they're gonna they're going to provide
really really nice prizes I'd like to
win some but I'm sure but no you are not
able to win them when you work for the
company and I well no because we give
some cool stuff away here on gamespot
that Chris doesn't ever get to have
hahaha I could touch it look at touching
yeah oh I'm gonna take home that close
uh well I mean so it's this battle how
long would a battle like this take I
think you're sort we're sort I feel like
they're we've sort of goaded you guys to
get right into it for the sake of the
demo but you know if you were if you
were like really sitting down really
wanted to win this one you arrange the
battles like when you get when you get
pretty experienced with it it's like
about 25 25 minutes 25 to 35 minutes and
then when you're just kind of figuring
things out it's like 45 to 55 minutes so
it's a lot it's are along the same lines
as like dota 2 or league of legends yeah
you know you get in you you spend spend
a good amount of time on a match and
there's a I mean there's a there's a lot
to it you know just like just like just
like those games like every every
character is very unique and then the
way that they play with the characters
around them is is really unique is also
yeah you gotta take so you need to know
your characters and the enemy and really
well yeah yeah which is a lot of
learning you guys
like online resources for this stuff
yeah should I imagine you're drawing
from established war machine cannon
right so are you using those same kind
of statistical values yeah a lot of the
tabletop game we've uh we've we've taken
the values and we've made them kind of
proportionally fit to to what we have
here so in some cases like they're one
for one okay but but we there's a lot of
there's a lot of resources for people
like you can you can select a you can
select an enemy unit and you can see all
of their everything that they can do
here and it's not in just yet but we
have we have pop-up text that comes a
little lane each individual thing and
then not and then there's what I need
there's a there's actually our people
the people that are already playing
right now have been writing like
detailed stuff like this guy does this
stuff and this is how you should use
them and people are starting to make
their own like guide so at some point I
think their information is gonna be
better than ours hey that's great crowd
sourcing the information that's a real
powerful way to get to create resources
in this day and age yeah already awesome
I mean they do such a such a great job
at it you know well if people are
intrigued by war machine tactics where
can they can they get it now or do they
have to sort of wait a little bit for
you so you can actually hop on you can
actually hop on Steam right now it's on
Steam early access where were heavily
soliciting feedback you know all the all
the information that we can get on like
what people think about the game and
balance and what you'd like to see and
all that and if you if you get it now
we're also we're also including a whole
new faction too so you'll have five
factions to play with and another eight
extra units so you get a total of like
20 20 extra units to play with when you
when the when the full game releases
right on hi any idea when the full game
is going to release a few months
actually no kid all right well I wish
you the best of luck in the remaining
saw Jay thank you for coming by and
showing off war machine tactics
absolutely that's on Steam early access
right now folks you can check it out